foreign
[Music]
this is Star Talk Cosmic queries Edition
I got with me my co-host Matt Kirsch and
Matt how you doing man I'm very good how
are you yeah you still got your probably
science podcast Rolling Along still
still got that going we're still
trucking on uh next time you've got
something big to promote and you need
that point zero zero zero one percent
bump
the Christian bump I guess yeah our
doors are open our microphone is is free
and ready to go I'm gonna wait until you
change the name to definitely science
and then maybe I'll come on the problem
you can do it as a one-off when you're
on the show we can do it for you so Matt
guess what we're going to talk about the
expanding Universe today
oh I I love these episodes yeah yeah and
one of the world's experts on this is
someone I came of age with we were like
in graduate school like at the same time
and went on to all the same conferences
I'm delighted to catch back up with her
Wendy Friedman Wendy welcome to StarTalk
thanks very much Neil it's great to see
you yeah we we were uh young a long time
ago
everyone was younger a long time ago I
think it works for everybody
so Wendy I got in my notes here you are
the John and Marion Sullivan University
professor of astronomy and astrophysics
at the University of Chicago as we all
know many of us know it's an institution
with a storied past in figuring out what
was going on in the early Universe
especially mixing our understanding of
particle physics with what went on in
the Big Bang and you devoted your life
to the expansion of the universe what
role dark energy is played in it Galaxy
evolution is Delight to have you on
start talk I just want to put that out
there and so many remind everyone what
the Hubble constant is just we've heard
of it and like what is it because we got
Hubble the guy the dude the the
astronomer then we have the Hubble
telescope and then we have the Hubble
constant so what's going on there yeah
all Hubble same Hubble Edwin Hubble and
uh Edwin Hubble is the man who
discovered that the universe is
expanding and the rate at which the
universe is expanding today is a
quantity that we call the Hubble
constant and what Hubble discovered was
that when he went and made measurements
of galaxies this was in the 1920s and we
didn't know at that time whether our own
Milky Way galaxy was the entire extent
of the universe or whether there might
be other galaxies like the Milky Way and
so we didn't know how far away the
objects were something that astronomers
called nebulae and Hubble set out to
study the nebulae and what he discovered
was that they were outside the Milky Way
itself there are many more galaxies in
the universe about a hundred billion of
them
and then he went on to discover that not
only are there other galaxies but they
are moon space is expanding and galaxies
are are going along with that expansion
of space and the rate at which that's
happening today is what we call the
Hubble constant after Edwin Hubble and
it gives us a measure of both the size
of the universe and its age so it's a
very important it's a fundamental
parameter in cosmology well you keep
saying it's value today that means it
was had a different value yesterday and
they'll have a different value tomorrow
so why the hell are you calling it a
constant
well it's confusing because the universe
is evolving and it did have a different
expansion rate in the past it will have
a different expansion rate in the future
because it's actually speeding up
but what we measure today locally in in
the universe around us in the Milky Way
or in another galaxy near us we will
measure the same expansion rate at the
current time so the Hubble constant is
the Hubble expansion rate
today
our time our time constant in our time
yeah you got it now if I remember
correctly because I'm that old to
remember it when the Hubble telescope
came around one of the primary goals of
it was to nail down the Hubble constant
and therefore the age of the universe
and the size of the universe which was
highly unknown at the time with warring
factions weren't even agreeing within a
factor of two and you spearheaded that
if I remember correctly so so the value
you got back then has that been uh
sustained over the years have better
measurements
and you're correct so when Hubble was
launched and it was in fact uh the the
project that the Hubble telescope was
built to Seoul it was the umbrella
project of course there are many things
astronomers wanted to do but this factor
of two got in the way of everything we
didn't know how old the universe was we
didn't know how far away galaxies were
so we didn't know how bright they were
we didn't know their masses Etc it was
it was a huge problem and so the size of
Hubble's primary mirror was set to allow
us to measure a certain kind of star
that lets us measure distances the same
kind of star that Edwin Hubble himself
used called the cepheid variable and so
the size of the mirror was was not
decreased budget considerations made the
telescope smaller than originally
envisaged but it allowed us to discover
cepheids in our nearby cluster called
the Virgo cluster and so yeah we had a
key project which I was a scientific
leader of co-led with Jeremy mold and
Rob kinnikit and we measured the Hubble
constant to an accuracy of 10 and got
around this factor of two resolve this
problem that had been pressing for many
decades and that has stood the test of
time so people argued between values of
50 and 100 for this Hubble constant we
got a value of 72 at the time with an
uncertainty of 10 and ever since then
the the value has stayed very close to
that maybe 73 74 now when it's based on
cepheid variables
so not many people get to say I'm
measuring the universe so that's that's
just kind of a cool thing to put on your
business card
is was is has that always been a known
thing or is the fact that it's speeding
up
a new piece of information the fact that
it's beating up was it came into uh a
point of being able to be measured
around the turn of uh of the Millennium
and
um it's interesting so what what's
happened is that not only is the
universe expanding as Edwin Hubble told
us but it's also speeding up in its
expansion with time
and that's something that actually was
allowed in Einstein's general theory of
relativity but Einstein rejected it
because there was one no evidence that
the Universe was expanding at all uh and
so he in fact added something into his
equations that that forced the universe
to be uh static
and he put a term in called the
cosmological constant to force the
university static when Hubble discovered
the expansion
Einstein is reputed to have said that
this was his biggest blunder because he
could have predicted the expansion but
this cosmological constant sort of came
and went over time as people thought
they found evidence for it
but it wasn't until the late 1990s when
it became possible to observe very
distant supernovae very bright
explosions in the distant universe that
showed that the Universe was actually
speeding up in its expansion and not
slowing down and that had been the
expectation that because of gravity the
universe would eventually slow down in
its expansion over time so Wendy what
you're saying is Einstein's biggest
blunder was saying that that was his
biggest blunder
well you know only Einstein can include
one of his biggest blunders is one of
his actual biggest scientific
contributions right if your blunder led
to a Nobel Prize by others discovering
their blunder right that's that's
completely crazy Einstein as badass as
you can get uh uh in in his day I feel
like one day uh a blunder of mine could
lead to maybe a Nobel Prize for medicine
really yeah I mean like for someone else
like someone else like oh I guess you
can take that out of a human or uh you
know
yeah no I wouldn't like aim for that
though I think that sounds dangerous oh
you never Aim so Matt you got questions
for us we've got a question solicited
from our patreon fan base and they have
exclusive access to this line of
questioning and we just said yeah we got
Wendy Dr Wendy with us and we are gonna
talk about the expansion of the universe
so let's do it
uh yeah so Fadi Hayek from Indianapolis
first before asking any scientific
questions wants to know the official
title of me
[Music]
no no we'll work on it we'll thank you
for that we'll work on it yes it's yeah
it needs to be decided and then how come
the universe is expanding faster than
the speed of light uh but Galaxy stars
and planets are not in a hurry to move
away from each other I mean the speed of
expansion is not only mind-boggling but
in a way Supernatural it should be
perceivable I'm not entirely sure what
fatty is getting at there but uh yeah so
what's up with that Wendy
so I think we probably heard that Albert
Einstein told us that nothing could
travel faster than the speed of light
and what Einstein told us was that no
information can go faster than the speed
of light but there is in fact no speed
limit for the universe itself and so
that's quite true there are parts of the
universe beyond where we can see light
uh that has traveled to us since the the
age of the universe the time that the
Universe has been here
um and we don't know anything about
those because no information can come to
us the universe is expanding faster than
the speed of light
so no violation no violation no
violation there's there's no violation
so we'll never there there is physically
no way to ever see those stars now and
they're basically gone they are they're
gone and they're getting further away
from anything that we can ever access
they're beyond our Horizon we cannot we
will not get information from them not
ever that's correct not ever that's kind
of sad that's kind of sad it is kind of
sad well and in fact we're living at a
time where we can see you know many many
hundreds of billions of galaxies but
there will be a time when except for our
own local neighborhood the maybe the
Virgo cluster and other clusters of
galaxies near us and this comes to the
second part of the question which is
that galaxies that are near to us or
they're interacting gravitationally all
galaxies are you know the force of
gravity falls off as the distance
squared
and so the galaxies that are near us are
gravitationally we're gravitationally
bound and so even with this acceleration
that force is strong enough to keep them
um in our observable universe but if we
came back in on 65 billion years we
wouldn't see all the galaxies in the in
the sky that we see assuming that we
understand enough now about what is
termed dark energy that is causing the
acceleration that's a separate question
because we don't yet understand the
nature of of the dark energy
so so you you say that the local ones
won't Escape past this Horizon is it if
you go far far enough in the future is
that possible that that would happen or
will that never happen will we always be
able to see that this stuff that's in
our immediate no well things like for
example we have in our own local group
of galaxies the Andromeda galaxy which
if you go to a dark part of the sky more
and more rare on Earth right now but you
can actually see Andromeda with the
naked eye but we will eventually collide
with Andromeda billions of years from
now uh it we we will we will be fine we
um stars are so far apart that we're not
going to have a collision with our sun
but the two galaxies will emerge and
that's been happening over time Galaxies
have been plunging into one another and
becoming uh you know larger and larger
uh so no the the galaxies that are
nearest to us and of course not ones
that are are sufficiently far away that
they won't fall into us but they still
we have enough gravitational attraction
that we will at some point uh look out
at the universe and not see most of what
we see today but I'm tucking tens of
billions of years in the future so this
isn't a situation where we need to send
like Bruce Willis up in a rocket to
deflect the Galaxy to stop it from
crashing into us right no it is that
situation I'm pretty sure
we're designing that mission now flying
two space shuttles simultaneously into
space we we got this
relief it's really interesting now
because it's possible to study the
evolution of galaxies and their
interactions over time via gravity and
so what we think of is distinct objects
have been trading stars and plunging
through each other and and eventually
merging that's just been part of our
Cosmic past it's it's a it it's a very
uh Dynamic place out there yeah in fact
Matt we for a while we call it the
mergers and Acquisitions uh part of
modern astrophysics and we have
inflation and all sorts of yeah all
manner of cultural reference there we're
going to take a quick break when we come
back more with my good friend Professor
Wendy Friedman one of the world's
experts on the expanding Universe when
we come back
we're back StarTalk Cosmic queries this
is the expanding Universe Edition you
got to do that every now and then just
to check up on it I got Matt kershen as
my co-host very cool Matt where do we
find you on social media
uh I'm at maccerson on Twitter at
underscore cushion on Instagram and then
probably science is my podcast excellent
Christian
if you just type English comedian Matt
Ki and then bang the keyboard Google
finds me okay okay
so Wendy we got more questions for you
all right let's see let's see what we've
got Matt give it to us yeah Jeremy Green
from Nevada that says love the show uh
with the James Webb Space Telescope
fighting galaxies that should not be
existing that soon after the big bang
how is that going to change thoughts in
cosmology and how the early Universe
formed okay let me back that up a second
and come back to you Wendy here Wendy
why should there be a time in the early
Universe where we don't expect galaxies
wait what's going on
so in the very earliest moments of the
universe we had of course the big bang
radiation from The Big Bang couldn't
reach us early on there was a very hot
plasma and it was too hot even for
hydrogen atoms to form so the photons
from The Big Bang would hit the
electrons in this plasma
and and we don't have any information
there at about 380
000 years after the big bang the
expansion had proceeded to the point
where the temperature had cooled enough
that you could form hydrogen and after
that the photons from The Big Bang could
stream out and we can detect them today
they're all around the background
radiation has been detected from The Big
Bang then with telescopes like Hubble we
can peer back into the universe and with
Hubble we can go maybe 12 billion years
back in time we could see tiny little
smudges that Hubble could barely resolve
and you you couldn't get detailed
information on those this is 12 billion
out of nearly 14 billion so that's
pretty far back
that's pretty good right 12 out of 14.
very very good but there's a region of a
space of time that we have actually
referred to as the Dark Ages which is
the period between when we can first
detect photons from The Big Bang 380 000
years after the big bang and maybe 12
billion years ago and and we have no
information about that time so one of
the main scientific goals of the J James
Webb is to study the Dark Ages and to
see galaxies forming witnessing directly
the first galaxies to form so we know
they're there we're in a galaxy we can
see these faint smudges but we have no
information or had no information about
that process and that's what's exciting
about James Webb is we're opening up a
whole new window and we needed an
infrared telescope to do that so but
aren't these galaxies weren't they found
in the Dark Ages I mean you wouldn't
expect that right
these new galaxies were finding yes they
are very they seem to have formed very
early on after after the big bang so
that you know and you're cool and you're
okay with that
I'm okay with that I mean I'm okay with
whatever the universe
you know tell the universe
[Laughter]
that's our job to go measure it and you
know I think that's one of the reasons
why I was excited about James Webb is we
had lots of theories for how Galax
information would happen and and you
know we're pretty certain about those
things but then you actually go and look
and you learn something new what we
learn I'm not sure yet I think we have
more surprises yet in store and in a way
that's the whole point of the telescope
right yeah yeah and and so right now
there's this I think
um excitement that maybe galaxies very
massive galaxies form very early on and
our current theories tell us there was
no time to do that you can't possibly
have galaxies that are that massive that
early
but I think we need to explore a lot of
other questions about you know what were
the stars like that formed early on are
they the same as the ones that are
forming today what was is there dust in
the early universe that we don't know
about or the properties different was
the star formation rate different
the way that they form the distribution
of masses so there's a lot of exploring
I think we need to do so you'll see
headlines like you know the Big Bang is
dead and
um standard cosmology is broken and I
think we need to just slow down a little
and and really understand what we're
seeing which is really interesting but
we don't yet know I think what it means
so you really should just get back to
the work on that right now
why are you doing this podcast bothering
me
you know you're losing precious minutes
here that perfectly plays into Alyssa
Dylan uh who asked is is the breaking
news is all the breaking news stories
related to James Webb's Space Telescope
findings hoaxes or all the fight or
rather findings challenging some core
ideas in astrophysics and astronomy
well I think you know we are challenging
ideas in astronomy and astrophysics and
I think you know whenever you get really
new information how you process that how
you get big enough samples how you
understand how things might have been
different at a different time in a
different environment it takes time to
settle those things out so we're at the
really exciting part which is hey we
don't understand this what's going on
here but in terms of of gaining
understanding I think that will take
some time but that's part of the fun of
doing science at the Forefront it's just
just to clarify when scientists on the
Forefront find something they don't
understand this is an exciting day it's
not a day to worry it's like oh my gosh
this doesn't fit let's find out why and
so but the Press makes it out like we're
all just sitting there with our legs up
on the desk basking in our Mastery of
the universe and then we get jostled by
some result and we're on the floor
trying to refine the drawing board just
screwing up ripping up paper uh yeah so
we're not doing the whole painting over
right right
regardless Wendy's always at the drawing
board I think that's the that's the
point here oh yeah I sort of envisaging
just Wendy just furious punching through
a straw boater and just stamping on the
floor every time
every time news telescope findings come
through just
yeah
we are living at an incredible age I
mean Hubble getting above the Earth's
atmosphere we were able to see things we
could never see before
um and same thing is happening with
James Webb it's opened up a whole new
wavelength regime that we didn't have
access to not in the same not with the
same sensitivity or resolution and so
we're learning new things it's what
makes science fun and I think you know
there's a tendency partly because of
when we go to school when you learn
science there's you know you're given a
problem and then you can look up the
answer in the back of the book and with
the universe there's no back of the book
to look up the answers
we have to observe you know read the
universe observe the universe experiment
to to um to see what it's done but that
we don't know the answer when we're when
we're looking when we when we first get
new data but the closest thing we have
to the back of the book the closest
thing we have is you show it to a
colleague and then and does this look
right to you you know I don't know let
me give did somebody let me get Susie
look does it look right to you not you
messed up Wendy you forgot to carry the
two you know
our version of this check of this this
this checking process are our colleagues
who yeah and and if they're doing their
job
it is their obligation to find out where
we messed up yes all right they're not
our friend if they say oh let's not tell
her you know
no it's one of the very unusual things
about the nature of science is that
you're you're always trying to find
what's wrong and what we've done before
how do we look at this wrong what can we
do to improve our measurements or yeah
check our theories right right
all right man keep it coming all right
Baron I mean asked a question from
Baron's 17 year old son who is taking AP
Physics and wants to be an engineer if
you're 17 they have their own account
they could like Fork up the five dollars
a month for patreon we'll take it this
case all right all right all right
okay what has been the most challenging
aspect of your work trying to understand
the age of the universe along with using
the James website telescope to ascertain
your research interests and big fan of
the show I love space Cosmos thank you
nice nice so Wendy do you know enough
math you ever have to go back into the
math book is all the physics did you get
that in graduate school is there more
physics do you have to check in on what
what are some of your challenges just as
a professional on that Frontier
yeah you know I I would answer it in two
ways I mean part of it is the theory or
understand physical understanding of the
nature of the universe which has changed
since I was a graduate student since you
were a graduate student you know and at
that point evidence for Dark Matter was
just becoming it's starting to be taken
seriously
um we hadn't yet learned about the
acceleration of the universe and dark
energy the idea of inflation was just
beginning uh so cosmology has changed a
lot and you have to keep up with the
changes but they're real Mysteries we we
don't know what uh is causing the
acceleration there's a Nobel Prize
waiting for someone there we don't yet
know what the nature of dark matter is
although their experiments all over the
world trying to discover the nature of
dark matter and and so there are just a
lot of open-ended questions right now
and uh and right now we're even asking
questions about whether the standard
model which is a model now that has dark
energy and dark matter
that comprises about 95 of the universe
and we don't know what it is so it's a
there are a lot of open-ended questions
right now
so um the other is the experimental side
and and what is you know what are the
challenges there and when you're making
measurements as we've gone along with
time we talked about the factor of two
uncertainty in the Hubble constant when
I began then we got to 10 now we've been
able to get to five percent I would say
confidently and there are some who say
we've even reached one percent if you're
trying to improve your accuracy and we
have to recall that we're measuring
astrophysical objects that are in some
cases
um tens of light years to hundreds of
light years to hundreds of millions of
light years away we're using the
properties of stars to gauge distances
and stars can be complex they have dust
in their atmospheres they're located in
regions with dust and the farther away
we're making the measurements the more
crowded those stars become because you
only have a finite resolution of your
detector and so there are
uncertainties that can creep into your
measurements and we constantly have to
be checking our own measurements to see
how we can improve them so those are
real challenges and they're both from a
theoretical perspective in the field of
trying to understand what we're
observing and then from a an observer's
point of view trying to make
measurements and increasing our accuracy
and being able to so not all data are
created equal and so you have to
you've got to know your data otherwise
you could be you know garbage and
garbage out yeah and it's been a history
of the subject yeah so why did Hubble
Hubble measured a value for his constant
of 500 were now you know so but a factor
of eight different than we measured
today and it had to do with problems in
the photographic detectors he used the
fact he didn't know about dust and other
kinds of issues like that and and we're
still confronting those in the higher
accuracy we need to confront our series
the harder it is to make these
measurements and so we always have to
remember that and keep testing ourselves
and and really trying to get more and
more uh accurate data and keep in mind
he found a phenomenon even though he got
the wrong number to measure it right I
mean that's an interesting fact here you
don't say oh he's way off so therefore
forget everything he did no the the
phenomenon is still real even though his
measurement of the phenomenon was very
far off right so no he made a remarkable
Discovery and it's clearly in the data
you can see that there is a relationship
between velocity and distance that you
know Bears his name this Hubble constant
the slope of that relation but he didn't
have the ability to make accurate
measurements and then again even when we
got better detectors it we had to wait
for Hubble to get above the Earth's
atmosphere because of this question of
resolution and now James Webb has four
times the resolution at the wavelengths
we're observing it and we can see now
these cepheids in our James Webb Space
Telescope data that pop out of these
beautiful images that are completely
smeared out in faint in Hubble's images
so each time we get a new facility we
get new capability and and uh and we can
do better
so astronomers never stop
bigger better
yeah there are more questions to answer
more more and more so the 17 year old
out there we've left a lot for you to do
there you go you're good so Matt give me
give me another one before the break all
right okay well this is one of those
questions where I don't know I don't
know how you begin to give an answer to
this one so I love these sort of
slightly esoteric ones I guess but okay
this one's for you Neil no yeah
the question to me that's not fair all
right
so also says please visit Vancouver and
is our universe young middle aged or old
how much time does it have left to exist
I like that I know Wendy can take that
when he can take that but we actually
have to take a break and when we come
back we're going to find out whether
Wendy thinks the universe is Young Old
decrepit or what it's
on StarTalk Cosmic queries the expanding
Universe Edition
we're back StarTalk Cosmic queries
expanding Universe Edition with Wendy
Freeman a professor of astronomy and
astrophysics at the University of
Chicago uh Wendy how do we find do you
have any social media footprint of your
own
not of my own University of Chicago has
a foot they have one so so you don't
have one so that means you actually are
in the lab do it you're you're actually
being scientifically kidding I don't
know I don't you know I have enough
things on my plate to do I yeah
productive oh my gosh okay phony if only
I had that willpower yeah yeah yeah so
we left off who's the person who asked
that question Matt that was Gavin Bamba
from Vancouver saying it's like Universe
young middle-aged or old and I guess you
can't just say age is just a number when
it's your job to calculate that number
to ever increasing levels of accuracy
so some years ago there was a book
called The Five ages of the universe and
I think it was by Brad Adams and Greg
Laughlin
and
I loved it because they
broke up the universe into periods of
time where everything happening in the
universe over that time was
approximately the same kinds of things
and so that leaves me wondering what
what age are we in today versus what
might be happening tomorrow it's an
interesting question because we're
actually living in an inflection point
and it's an interesting one it appears
to be a coincidence that we happen to be
living at the time where this dark
energy that we're referring to is just
becoming the dominant component in the
universe so in the early Universe first
radiation dominated then matter that was
one of the errors right right and and
now the universe is just starting to be
dominated by the accelerating phase and
by by the dark energy and so before
before we were talking about the
existence of dark energy it was possible
to calculate an age for the universe and
you could predict with some certainty
along
um the universe would uh you could say
the universe for example would be
infinite or if it had enough matter it
would recollapse but now that there's
this dark energy component we can't say
for certain what the next phase will be
because we don't know what the
fundamental physics is that is driving
the acceleration so will there be a new
phase I think that's just something that
um either
some new Theory could predict
um but there isn't a theory right now
that Wendy we brought you on the show to
give us answers don't tell us how much
we don't know what good why why
you know it's one of the things that
often happens in science right the more
you learn the more questions that you
raise yeah there it is everything called
you know one of the the fundamental
mystery in cosmology it's one of the
biggest unknowns in science right now it
really is a mystery we we don't
understand it okay all right science
does not have all the answers if that's
my answer yeah I've heard people say
this is this is a mystery not even the
scientists know therefore it's aliens or
something right they quickly go to some
conclusion that because then the fact
that a scientist doesn't have the answer
is their measure that it must be
something so exotic and so mystical and
magical rather than just no we're just
we got top people working on it just
chill out no it is Mystical and magical
and what's happened in the last couple
of decades is there's so much new data
that have you know come from so many
different directions measuring how fast
galaxies are moving measuring the
radiation from The Big Bang are
measuring the expansion and yet the
basic model is holding up you know there
are perhaps cracks and we'll learn
something from where those cracks appear
but overall there's been tremendous
progress right yeah there are things we
don't understand all right all right
Matt give me some more I'm combining two
questions on this because that's always
fun to do when two people ask things
that are playing in the same I still
want to hear who asked each of the two
questions very much so because firstly
Adam Paradise who is a long time fan and
first-time Patron so definitely give you
a shout out welcome to the club Adam
so uh and is finally happy to have a
question what happens to black holes
during slash after the Big Rip do they
have enough energy to resist the rip and
if so do they enact any force on the
rest of the universe that maybe wasn't
large enough to matter before Universal
expansion slow down I love it says thank
you for all your time and then Gina
Martin from North Carolina and says
thank you for all the stalemite all you
do for the Stellar Miner community at
large says Adam and then Gina from North
Carolina says I recently heard Neil on a
previous episode explaining the big rip
and how the expansion of the universe
would eventually cause Mata on an atomic
level to be ripped or stretched apart
would that not cause nuclear fission
reactions or explosions similar to big
bang and create a whole new universe so
let's uh let's get to the horse's mouth
here Wendy what is the latest
scholarship on the big rip and because
it's to me it's the most terrifying
thing I've ever
learned and read about so but but you're
in the middle of it so tell us what your
tell us what you're allowed to say
I think you know at the I think the
thing to say is that present there's no
evidence that there's going to be a big
room I think there's nothing that we
could point to
um in terms of evidence that would
suggest that there's going to be a big
rip now you can't say that with absolute
certainty because again there are things
we don't understand yet about the
evolution of the universe but but wait
wait but if you don't if you if you
confessed you didn't know we don't know
about dark energy and what's causing it
but we can measure it
isn't the measurements sufficient to say
if this keeps up
what's going to happen it's just a
simple sort of extrapolation
that's not allowed you don't you guys
don't do that behind closed doors yeah I
think we have to be careful with
extrapolations and and I think with time
the situation will become clearer but
we're talking about times it's important
to say that our so far in the distant
future that
uh I personally am not going to spend a
lot of my time worrying about it I'm not
going to worry about the sun exhausting
hydrogen in its core yet
I think Wendy's in denial
I don't want to think about it pressing
issues I don't want to think about it
yeah more information
sorry but go ahead but tell us what's
going to happen
she's in denial man it's clear I see the
signs are obvious no no I I Wendy you're
being very practical or what you're
saying not to put words in your mouth
but I think what you're saying is that
it is sufficiently speculative to not
devote your hard earned time lab time
and Telescope time on that problem
relative to others that are less
speculative and more uh tangibly
answerable is that a fair
characterization of what you just said
okay there you go all right since you
mentioned time Liam Cochran from Rhode
Island I hope I pronounced that
correctly said if time is relative how
do we accurately predict the age of the
universe with the age we predict here on
Earth differ from an age predicted from
another point in space for example near
a black hole yeah I'd love that yeah one
day who who keeps time in the universe
you're telling me how old the universe
is with the black hole agree with that
yeah what if two universes one went to
the moon and one didn't go
so what we're doing in a very practical
sense is that you know we can measure
how far away galaxies are at the current
time we can measure the speed at which
they are receding from us the universe
is expanding
and so we can measure as I said earlier
the Hubble constant which is the
expansion rate at the current time and
then it's it's not unlike you know a
movie if you run it in reverse right
except that you use in language of
mathematics Einstein's general theory of
relativity
upon which The Big Bang Theory is based
and uh and and then calculate what the
age how long the universe has been
expanding given the amount of matter in
the universe and given the amount of
this dark energy you can then calculate
what the age is and we get an age of
about 13.8 billion years yeah but whose
clock are you using why why is your
clock the right clock and not the clock
that was around if I had a clock in the
early universe is it measuring the time
that you're measuring now
the rate of change of time I mean is
that
it's so what essentially Einstein's
theory tells us is that
um we have so it anywhere in the
universe because of this uniform
expansion anywhere we made this
measurement if I go to the Andromeda
galaxy if I go to another galaxy another
galaxy another galaxy I would look
around and I would see all galaxies
receding from us I would appear to be
the middle of that expansion and I would
measure the same expansion rate
okay
all right so macroscopically that's how
that works because the question talked
about the time around a black hole we
all saw that famous scene in the movie
Interstellar where the guys are waiting
for the folks down on the on the black
hole planet and they come back 15
minutes later by their time but like 20
years or something had elapsed on the
orbiting spacecraft waiting for them and
so I think that's the source of the
questioning that's coming onto the table
now uh whose clock are we using but if
the if the really weird messed up time
is right in the vicinity of black holes
then and black holes are just dotting
the universe that's not the clock you
want to use for any of this right so in
the vicinity of a black hole when you
have strong gravity moving clocks are
good are gonna run slow in your strong
gravitational field
Einstein tells us that things work
differently right and you're precisely
right you don't want to make
measurements macroscopic you know on
average of the universe which is a giant
place right you don't want to be using
these very high density regions to make
your measurements wrong place Matt did
you see for those who were only viewing
uh Wendy extended her arms to gesture
how big the universe is I think that's
that is so quaint you can't help it I
definitely use my hands when I talk
versus this big whatever your did you
get the point the arms reaches yeah I
feel I feel sorry for the audio only
people who are still struggling to
picture it but uh well just picture
Wendy extending her and that's how big
the universe is because it's expanding
too she nailed it right there right
there so Matt let's let's get a couple
of uh fast lightning rounds okay yeah we
got a few questions left I think we can
get through all of the ones I've got in
front of me so Rob love while we're
talking about black hole says why are
they called Black why not black stars
after all they're formed from Stars it
seems like a fanciful name now leads to
questions and confusions like what's
inside a black hole in fact we know it's
condensed matter but do we know it's
condensed matter because is it still
condensed matter once it's collapsed
into a black hole he's got black hole
issues
so okay sure to remove that so you know
if you imagine the Earth and you imagine
growing something up it falls back down
if you throw it with enough velocity it
can escape from the earth and the same
is true you have enough matter dense
enough
um what becomes a black hole is that it
it's so dense that not even light the
escape Velocity is such that not even
light can escape so that's the nomer
black hole came because no light can
escape from it but we won't get into
do you fall in and light doesn't come
out yeah a whole black hole that's got
to be better than Black Star right
because it's not right no I'm I'm with
you on that guys I think we just ran out
of time damn damn all right Wendy it's
been a delight it's been too long uh can
we keep you on our Rolodex for for
future James Webb discoveries
cosmological discoveries it's been a
pleasure talking to you it's nice to see
you again after all these years and yeah
sure yeah definitely Matt always good to
have you there man
it's great to be here all right all
right we're ending this episode of
cosmic queries expanding Universe
Edition I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson you're a
personal astrophysicist as always keep
looking up
[Music]